rosette sayer is trying to create some
christmas cheer at her home in gaza the
tree's up and her grandson is helping
with the decorations
for his sake she's trying not to let her
disappointment show
she'll not see many members of her
family and hasn't seen some for years
because of the blockade on gaza some had
to leave home to find work overseas
in the past we used to get together and
gather all the family at christmas but
today there's no one left they've all
gone abroad and christmas has no flavor
we can't even travel from here to meet
them because of the restrictions
those christians left in the gaza strip
had to abandon any hope of celebrating
christmas in the holy cities of
bethlehem and jerusalem because of
israeli security restrictions
in 2019 and 2020 no permits were granted
and although this year israel said 500
of the 1 000 christians in gaza would be
allowed to go
there's still a major problem
people here say israel only grants the
permits to one or two members of the
same family which would mean entire
families being split up at christmas if
they traveled
permits could be granted to half of the
same family after we all apply either
just the parents or just the kids but
either way it means that we can't travel
our sense of joy is missing we wish
israel would give us our right to visit
our holy sites like everyone else in the
world
[Music]
muslims in gaza have long shared
christmas celebrations with the minority
christians lighting the tree and sending
christmas greetings to each other this
year we are able to do it and we insist
to do it it's the symbol for love peace
freedom and we will continue doing this
we hope next year
we will go further to have
the genuine freedom for palestinian
people based on just and peace
and we hope that we all palestinian
people live in such freedom across
palestine
prayers are held in the seoul orthodox
church in gaza but there is a feeling
christians here are missing out on the
experience enjoyed by others of their
faith
christmas for christians in gaza remains
incomplete but they pray and hope that
next year they would be able to reunite
with family and friends in bethlehem or
elsewhere
al jazeera gaza